is absolutely it right i genuinely feel
that way about plenty of situations in
which a minority is being oppressed
right and other people need to recognize
that this is not their battle so but
that's what i'm saying like in the case
of women i think people should be
excluded from us
because they're not women and like we
have our own issues and we have things
that we fight for and are specifically
to women right i don't think you get to
pretend to be a woman just like i can't
pretend to be black right
like i don't like i don't think you get
to like take away you get to take away
our awards you get to take away
um our our athletics
you get to take away our all of our
women's only spaces okay they're they're
taking these away from us and just like
if there was like you know black lives
matter if someone said okay let's make
it white lives matter like like that
would be that that people would be in an
uproar they would be yeah you know but
now um i just remembered this whole
thing um when it comes to like the
swimmers right like how you brought up
um leah thomas and
how this person had
i guess they blew away the competition i
assumed like they oh yeah
in first
place they were like 90 seconds behind
or some crazy stuff like that here's the
thing with
yeah here's the thing with battling um
biological
uh situations and
being put in a certain category for
competition right
when we look at someone like michael
phelps
he does not produce lactic acid in his
legs okay but he blows away the
competition every single time because he
can't produce it that we know what like
that lactic acid in our calves feels
like i'm gonna be honest i don't know i
don't know so lactic acid is what builds
up after um long-term training right so
it's like the burning sensation that you
feel in your calves or like your legs
more likely
um because he can't produce that he's
already at an advantage so naturally he
will have a much longer stamina however
he's been allowed to um compete his
entire swimming career
so does that mean that he should not
have been allowed to compete because he
was at an advantage at that point and
this is just a question i'm asking like
not whether or not i believe that he
doesn't he says he doesn't
not produce it he produces half as much
lactate which is a huge difference
compared to the average person i think
that's okay that's like
i know a girl that's six five
okay okay like and she had a huge
advantage when it came to recruiting
right if you're 65 you have a d1 but
that's an expectation for sports
your height like your height and build
are the two things that coaches and
recruiters look at the most right right
but i'm saying i think there's a
difference between having an advantage
but you're still you're still a
biological manners biological woman okay
like i think there's a difference
between just having an advantage you
know amongst your group okay and
having them come into our group and
blowing all of us out of the water okay
because like imagine imagine jessica you
know how hard we train we train so hard
yeah
bro i've been in this damn sport for
nine years so i understand now imagine
working your whole life and you having
to sit the bench this year because a
dude's in front of you
like like
it's not it's not fair i mean no matter
what i'm not going to um
disrespect that person's identity and
all that i will be upset i will be
honest because it's like i know at the
end of the day if that person's not been
on estrogen for long enough they're not
going to have the same
even close to biological build as me and
me knowing that i have trained so hard
to get to whatever point i need to be
it's going to be done up for me i don't
think there's ever a point because let's
let's even take height okay
i'm
i'm tall i'm on the top one percent of
height for females
i if amongst men i'm in the top 15
percent of height
the reason that i compete well you see
me compete i'm strong and i'm tall yeah
i have long arms but amongst men i'm not
that strong i'm not that tall and i
don't have that long of arms
because 15 of men are taller than me i'd
be blown out i would have no opportunity
and it's like how is that fair i get you
like no i don't i don't disagree like i
i fully see both sides of the situation
because no matter what
i want to respect um
trans people wanting to be able to
compete now i'll be honest like back in
high school at least before i did at
least a little bit more research on this
right i believed that they should have
had their own um
like league you know yeah but the reason
why i believe this is because i'm one of
those people where it's like if you
don't like the way something is do
something about it right so something
that upset me constantly
was seeing um
trans women get upset about not being
able to be a model for victoria's secret
right um now personally i could give a
[ __ ] about victoria's secret they're not
even that good no more uh it's all fenty
baby
but
um i felt like you know what if these
people aren't accepting you
do something else make your own company
make your own lingerie company if you
want like
if you want make your own trans modeling
company or agency i mean right because i
genuinely feel like we have more of a
platform to do what we want right at the
end of the day it's not the same as like
the 60s you know where it like someone
would shoot us down for it right and
because of that like i i again i don't
really see what i mean i i could see the
argument for abortion right like
i'm sure feminists like would rather
have more and more abortion rights fine
like i i understand that at least but
outside of that like
i can't see what on earth we're fighting
for like to be honest like what we need
feminism for
because i guess things are quite equal
now yeah there's nothing stop as you
just said there's nothing stopping us
from going and starting whatever company
we want to start i'll tell you what it
is like but that's why i was saying
what we're fighting for more is just
going against assault and rape and
um
like bodily autonomy like i said like i
really think that's our main um thing
because you know what i realized like
even when i speak to other people about
women's rights
none of us are really complaining about
like
you know [ __ ] like not getting paid
enough for like not getting
opportunities or anything like that if
anything some of us are getting a little
bit more opportunities because we're
pretty and like this and that you know i
i think i hear girls say that all the
time on my show they talk about pay gap
yeah i've brought it up dude there's a
pay gap i will i won't go against you
they know why there's a pickup though po
that's the question
um
so
does my voice irritate you
i don't think he's i think he's just
trying to i'm actually asking a question
like does like do they know the reason
for the pay gap a lot of times no they
think it's like the patriarchy or
society right but it's not it's women's
choices right
but um the most high-paying jobs
right
women aren't necessarily willing to do
them but there are plenty of situations
where women will be in the same um
what's the word um same position i'll
just say like same job position as a lot
of other men within the same company
let's say
that realize that they are getting paid
less than their male counterparts who
even may have been at the company for a
far less amount of time than they have
been right now that that's more of a
company issue that's illegal i can't say
that like that's like a statewide or
country-wide issue why that is chesca
though
because of personality differences
between men and women men are more
disagreeable
so if they get offered a salary they're
more likely to say f that'll go work for
another
screw or they're more likely to try and
negotiate a better deal yeah or
negotiate or say i'm not going to take
that
and like in that case i think i'm just
around a lot of ambitious women then
because i feel like i don't know anybody
like that but like i said i can only
speak from my perspective it's kind of
like okay in this conversation right
who who's more pleasant to talk to me or
sarah
you've been said no but it's because of
personality differences right like he's
more disagreeable i'm more agreeable
because i'm a woman
and we naturally like we
i'm disagreeable
but but it's not it's not a bad thing
right because you know sarah can have
some really cool moments for like on the
on the internet you know but
but like but like you see what i'm
saying like it's the same thing in in a
company like like sarah would probably
be more likely to say oh screw that i'll
go work for someone else or i'm not
going to take that job or i'm gonna get
enough fine yeah
yeah i would
in that it's true because i would in my
workplace i'd be like hang on a minute
so i'm doing this i'm doing that and i'm
doing that and this is what you're
paying me i know some or i'll go down
below i know a place that wants me for
the same job but they're going to pay me
x
what are you willing to do about that
right well and and and the the thing is
even with my channel i i run all of my a
lot of my decisions through men because
i know they're naturally better at that
yeah they can get you the best deal yeah
like like um we're talking about
bringing on a producer now and i'm
having my manager talk to him because do
you drive what do you drive
i'm saying so there's a reason why when
men go to a mechanic and women go to a
mechanic women get charged more than men
yeah right because the men were like
what it's not what no but i know no my
other mechanic can no no that's not that
we'll be like how much is it okay yeah
but you see like that's not patriarchy
that's personality differences no i
totally agree with that like
um
me on the other hand
i know how to handle those types of
situations but i think that's because i
was raised by my dad and i have dated
guys who give me insight on these kinds
of things you know like when it comes to
cars for example if i were to have a car
a mechanic is never going to get me
right just know that these [ __ ]
are never going to get me yeah but um
but that's the thing
we don't prioritize teaching women these
kinds of things at the end of the day
either you know like we have to think
about it like it's very
stereotypical like dad teaches son how
to throw a baseball and how to fix a car
and the daughter is gonna go play with
the doll or whatever like we
naturally in society we are a little bit
more traditional we're not thinking
about teaching our kids these things
until it's like too late half the time
well i don't think it's a bad thing i
don't think we should have to try to
change how we are because i know i don't
i don't think so i think it's just um
important to keep in mind that
these things are less like gender-based
and more just like survival skills right
like knowing how to not get
ripped off by your mechanics so that
your car can make it longer kind of
situate like that's just something you
should teach your kid period yeah but
like i don't know i think it's just more
gender-based but you do have to
understand that when a mechanic sees a
woman walk in and when he sees a man
walking he's thinking two different
things
yeah yes it's too
he and he and if he has looked your car
over
and he's looked the man's car over even
if he's trying to you know get the best
deal out of both of you he's gonna he's
going to approach the situation with a
little bit more tact when it comes to
the man